good morning john let's have this
conversation i feel like every single
decided that i just want to have lots of
really tough conversations on
vlogbrothers let's let's take these
let's face it head-on john i have a
problem and it's name is meat let's get
this out of the way there's definitely
some conflict going on between uh the
vegetarians vegans of the world and the
rest of the world i'm gonna talk about
why i think that is in this video and
i'm gonna start with the fact that
vegetarians are right yes animals raised
for food do not have nice lives and even
if they did they would still be killed
in the prime of their lives so that i
could have a tasty snack yes the amount
of food eaten by animals who will later
be eaten is massive and so as more
people eat meat more land has to be put
under cultivation yes livestock
contribute massively to climate change
and are a primary reason for
deforestation and yes most people don't
need to eat meat to be healthy and there
are reasons both ways like more than a
billion people make at least some of
their living from livestock you don't
want to take all of those people's
livelihoods away all at once but as the
global population grows as the global
economy grows it is very difficult to
argue that vegetarianism is not a good
thing basically the important thing here
is vegetarianism allows more people to
have more food with less impact
it's good and so when someone tells me
that i should be a vegetarian or leaves
a comment on a video asking me how do i
justify eating meat i have no recourse
but to say that they are right and that
i am wrong but that i will continue
eating meat because i'm the kind of
person who has a hard time controlling
myself and it's hard enough not to eat a
half a bag of oreos for breakfast now my
personal willpower aside there's a
fundamental conflict going on here i
live in a society where eating meat is
normal and being a vegetarian is not
it's montana you guys like there are
places in america where vegetarianism is
very normal this is not one of them but
there's a difference between acting in
accordance with society's expectations
which will very rarely get you
criticized and is definitely the easy
thing to do and actually living in a way
that is best for the future and for
people and for all of the organisms on
the planet and that's the reality of
meat eating it is a thing that i don't
need to do but i do despite the fact
that it makes the world worse for
current animals and future people this
is a big one for our society but there
are lots of examples of this like i've
always found it a little bit immoral
that i spend money on things that are
not necessary like coca-cola and flying
to san francisco and that fifth ticket
to the force awakens when there are
people dying of preventable diseases i
do those things instead of giving that
money to save the children for the same
reasons that i eat meat because it's
easier it's simpler i like them and i'm
not perfect but it's also more than that
like
acting in accordance with society to a
certain extent isn't just the easy thing
to do it's also
kind of the only thing to do i've
experienced this you can only do so much
breaking with culture before you become
extremely uncomfortable it's very hard
to find self-worth it's very hard to
find connection like imagine if every
time i saw someone buy a coca-cola i
like mumbled under my breath like you
know there are people dying of
preventable diseases i would not have a
lot of friends so why are people annoyed
by vegetarians because they have the
audacity to work extremely hard to live
in accordance with their values and
because those values conflict with the
values of society at large people don't
want to be told that the way that they
live their lives and the things that
they enjoy are making the world less
good especially when you got other stuff
to worry about but look as frustrating
as i'm sure both sides can find this at
times this cultural conflict is not a
bad thing i honestly believe that we're
on our way to a better brighter future
and 200 years from now people will think
it's ridiculous that we ate meat the way
that we do there is no reason not to
appreciate vegetarians for working very
hard to live in accordance with their
values and i completely understand their
desire to convert me and other people to
their cause to have us eat less or no
meat so i am thankful for you all of you
people who tell me to not eat meat and
yet i'm going to continue eating less
but not no meat because it's easier it's
simple i like it and i'm not perfect
john i'll see you on tuesday